SHUKRAINIAN FARMER AD FRASTHEI H
FI
AINE DOE S ATED
THRLD COULD T OD ON
SCRAMBLING TO SAVE
CAN.
EXCLUSY ter: A WAR AGAINST ONE .
CNN SHS
UNING THN
RMO PROTECT THEIR
UNL ON, S
WHE  KIND OFERF
R W UKRAINIANS AREA
DEADLY
EC
RUSSROCKETATED OUT OF THE FIEL S
HES.
>>S ANOTHER SHELEA
EARSHOSSN  BE HARVESTEWITHIN
WRECKAG .
ARMORED PEONIC YOURMERS OU HARVN
ELIT
WEEEG
CRATERS FROM
ROBABLLE OTH BRAVE
FAL BRINHE  ONL F IS 3,WHEAT R'I
BLOCKADED RA WAY FOR BE
SOLD EXCEP A
S CA OF  ADED BY RUSSIAN
THE NG MON, THE INIAN MID RUSSI
ISNDE BLAC
HAS  DANUBVER.
UKINE ACTIVATESOVIETS WATERWAY D
ONLY HANDLACTIONUKRAS GO.
THIS WEERAINIAN/RUSSN
MEETINGS AIPLE
BUKR F CTODEADLY TTSLAND
T TOSK TR NEXTISE FAEROWS NOR SH
LY W
I VAN WATSONN,UKRAINE.
EDF . ALEDIONS ITAO EXPORTS OF .
P,
A STEP,  ENSURING THE  SECURE E
A RAY OFUCH E GL FOOD SYSTEM. S
CATO KEEP
ITS SIDE OE BA
GOVERNME
>> RUSEME TARGETING
ORM FIELDS.
AND RESELLING UKRAINIACROPS.
BWHEA TYOE EYLS
WASS
S        SH
THEY T EQUIPME  EQUIPMENT.
O RIGHT NOW, ASIDEM , , THE DANR
FACE AS LL, S ALSOHE WHAT TH TH
OD ORU  OF THE BLAC.E'S NEWS ASE
T DEAL TH
RUSSIA,ALW UKRAINORGRAIFRS. HRC
EDOFFICIS RME PROCS  PROGRESS OF